[Music]
boy boy we've got a healthy baby boy
look at you
hi there do you think about perfect
that's a good name there he is there he
is dirty yet
[Music]
welcome back to dirty Rd chapter 22
season 3 as you can tell based on also
last week's chapter that things are a
little different we're gonna play
fallout 3 isn't that right Jake yep
we've been doing Red Dead for a long
time we're kind of starting to run out
of things to do and we figured fallout
might be a good one to see where see
where our DS adventure takes us and who
knows we may go back to red dead at any
point well I'm sure we will I am sure we
will too but for now we're gonna give
fallout 3 a shot because yet as you said
I think this game is gonna work pretty
well and lines up nicely with dirty
Artie's character
yep yeah hell of a [ __ ] lock there
dad well let's let's turn them all down
so we have a whole bunch of points
except luck we'll leave that it okay I
think we're gonna agree that
intelligence we don't necessarily need
okay agility probably not I've played
enough Red Dead Redemption to know I
mean like maybe not charisma but I feel
like he has an authoritative way to him
I think we should add some little spring
charisma to five okay and I think we
should bring Artie is pretty strong if
not stronger than five all right yeah
let's go ten for sure well we got 11
points we can adjust to perception I
don't think he's a very perceptive
[Laughter]
endurance he can fly under a lot excuse
me I mean he hasn't heard a lot yeah
yeah
so here we are 10 strength to perception
10 endurance 5 charisma and 10 lakh I
don't think his luck is all that great
personally I think charisma you could
bump up okay I mean I don't know you
feel about this but I think intelligence
and agility do not need in yeah they
don't need any be the babies perception
is a little better okay
I wish we could just go ahead with that
but I think we need to actually use all
the points I say okay all right now what
is this dad mess I don't like that
flying metal widow this party's pretty
good I guess for a little kid
balloons party hats I would it kill you
not it was my party though remember how
my dad got Andy to do magic tricks oh
right
you weren't invited to my party bad man
it was really fun no the cakes were whoo
it's a girl how do you like that pit boy
son fit all right and everything want to
do that your boys the best friend you'll
ever have
besides you can't get it off biometric
seals etc okay some stories about trying
to take them off the old folks fear lack
I used to ride a horse I used to be a
man there's so many people talking ten
years old goodness listen to me ramble
[Music]
young people were more polite back in my
day respected their elders I'm hungry
stupid robots we troll you got coupons
again that's pretty good
I kind of like sorry you did that you
are later I'm going to kill you little
surprise present Jonas is waiting for
you downstairs on the reactor level go
ahead now you Jonas you doing down here
young man
Oh kids weren't allowed down on the
reactor level care Nick Jonas were
present oh I see now that you're ten
you're all business
well then mister we'd better get to it
happy birthday by the way hang on one
more minute I think I hear someone
coming I can't wait to kill Butch Jonas
I got a list Berlin let's all ready for
your surprise yes yes in Swan regardless
I think you'll like this one your own BB
gun so what do you think what to give it
a try what's easy enough there's only a
BB gun
okay weird a matter let's go try it out
you got any hatchets some shotguns even
like a pump-action shotgun dad well what
do you think you can come down here and
whatever I'm sorry you feel that way if
you don't want it I'm sure I can find
some i displace I'm sick of the two dead
yeah alright whatever
[Music]
[Laughter]
am i doing a good job dad good work it's
one last round notes to deal with let's
get a picture together capture the
moment hey Jonas get a picture of me
with the donuts get over here as far as
I can tell you're a perfectly healthy 16
year old boy to take your goat exam yeah
that's good
where's my BB gun I want to bring it to
class now as I play your vault suit back
oh why don't you just leave me a lot hey
look it's smart-mouth afraid never back
up fancy words right now
so beating you got him okay come on
Tunnel snakes this little [ __ ] isn't
worth our time Oh baby say butch you're
the boss
tunnel snakes rule cut it out fine let's
go don't mess with the tunnels well you
made it all set for the goat that's
blood it really isn't that bad question
six
Oh mr. Abernathy has locked himself in
his quarters again and you've been
ordered to get him out how do you
proceed would you put for the last time
yep yep let him rock do you come on
you've got to wake up
Oh No you've got to get up right now if
my father's men catch you here I don't
know what will happen what did we did we
hook up last night you're a baseball bat
yes yes yes yes
[Music]
you gotta help me my monster trap I know
I bought but you can't walk away and let
it die just because I was an [ __ ] no
that's exactly right
yep yeah real bastard you know that
welcome to vaulteq yeah yeah oh that
should do it
oh he's going okay oh no we lost karma I
guess that's like the honor system back
in my other universe
guess what didn't like it either it's
our only chance
don't you see
I'm trying to kill you come back here
you thought radroaches we're bad you
ain't say nothing my friend thank you I
hope you're here to turn yourself I'm
here to kill you my friend a regrettable
incident actually all right oh you
trying to run away
Oh
get you ass back here oh man not a mo
you should give us that password
you're gonna dad stop what yes
she just knocked out in a way we really
you know closing up different what is
going on oh it's Jones notes from dad
and I could probably make a fire out of
that
[Music]
good you're leaving I guess you were
trying to help me but you you didn't
have to kill him I did hey George
Gillian a game away the only reason I'm
not calling the guards is out of respect
for your dad my eyes uh what the hell is
that noise
[Music]
we leveled up
[Music]
eleven skill points what should we do
there's really only realistically like
three or four these not much of a
bartering kind of we want to get
explosive size so we cannot yeah energy
weapons I have no idea what the hell
that is this is for explosives on a
melee oh that's good so this is probably
perfect very imperfect we do like
baseball oh look at this shitty little
town I like it reminds me a home
frag grenades in here sick where'd you
come from rope you into finding me too
huh
well you're not getting a damn thing
from me that's it Wow more drugs I love
drugs over over I know this is just like
old times more drugs she's dead
whiskey oh oh you're sheriff huh sheriff
do not claim any Jane's gonna be that's
fine fine just as long as we understand
each other
this here is my town these are my people
you so much as breathe wrong and I'm
gonna [ __ ] India hey hey watch this
mm-hmm it's strong all right Oh getting
out of here no no it's the sheriff no
he's done he's forgotten sorry about
that
well I say next episode we'd go to ten
penny Tower and we get ourselves that
was it called a somethin fusion I don't
know let's just blow it up this pulled
in this stupid town I hate that sheriff
I hate this town we're gonna blow it up
and now it's time for show us your arty
hashtag show us your arty where you guys
send in your own creations of dirty arty
first up
yeah first up is from blue Nova Corgi
this person is sent in some other art
before but this is the most recent and
it's it's a nice little composition
we've got evil arty we've got already
trying to be good I don't think such
thing is good already and there's just
Steve too with trees on his face because
he likes running into them yeah I guess
by the power of the beans I thought this
one was pretty good because it is
he's very messy yeah family you're right
that is a very different kind of that's
not the mud we're used to you know no
that's that's some and some roads grime
that's some unique roads grime for sure
yep very awesome this one is this is rad
rad start er D raccoon arty talking
about brooms no no dr. Artie the doctor
is in yeah that's a good one do you like
my lamp it was definitely the end of the
episode where we realized we didn't have
any friends over him
oh my god this is from I almost partly
included this just because of their
Twitter handle it's pissy pissed boy
that's amazing but they did the good bad
the ugly with Artie's in I think they
match up pretty well they really do they
really do that's fantastic wow this got
oh do another movie poster that's Souter
well done
Wow me Anna Morgan and the outlaws of
the last score that's super awesome it's
really cool now this is awkward
that scared me I don't know how to
pronounce this person's Twitter handle
but it'll be in the in the corner but
sheckly she's something like that I saw
that and that scared me
look at the eyes yeah that's really
scary and this guy behind him his mother
died in the middle is from skunk Johnny
and there's a dead skunk of course the
first [ __ ] Johnny and this guy was just
like bits of I don't know stomach laying
around exactly yes I'm intestine and he
also looks like he's possessed or
something his eyes his pupils are just
not there
dude look even his shoes are made of
skunks yeah that's so awesome the cutest
RT I've ever seen that is the cutest
already look at like how he's like all
hair his face is all hand girl but yes
face even like in between his eyes
that's so awesome and that's it that's
awesome one for thank you all so much
please continue to send them we'll add
them into these chapters that's gonna do
for this episode thank you guys so much
we'll see you next week
[Music]